whether you're a Scrooge Stan or you've
already broken out your favorite holiday
sweater Netflix is hoping to make those
long cold winter nights more bearable
with its december offerings here's all
the best stuff coming to Netflix in
December 2019 did you feel that it was a
shiver going down your spine and you
better get used to it
Netflix will be streaming quite a few
thrillers and chillers in December 2019
the question is can you handle it on
December 1st you can hunker down and
watch dead kids this Filipino film
involves a gang of teenagers who attempt
to kidnap an arrogant school bully
things get complicated
and very dark indeed then on December
9th
he should brace yourself for the 2017
critical darling it comes at night the
film centers around two families both of
whom are toughing it out in a
post-apocalyptic world expect plenty of
paranoia doom
dread and death happy holidays on
December 25th sweethearts start
streaming on Netflix the film tells the
story of Jen a frantic shipwreck
survivor played by Kiersey Clemons
thanks to a nocturnal sea monster the
very real possibility of starving to
death is the very least of her concerns
and if you're in the mood for handsome
bookish stalkers that like to kill
people
we've got just the ticket the Netflix
creep fest U is back for a second season
on December 25th you're gonna love it
like really really love it you realize
I'm not a maybe I'm the
Netflix has loaded its december schedule
with tons of stand-up specials on
December 3rd Tiffany Haddish gives us
black Mitzvah which finds the actress
and comedian discussing her Jewish roots
and her growing success but funny then
on December 12 British comedian Jack
Whitehall gives us Christmas with my
father which will find Whitehall and his
dad sharing a West End stage for a night
of laughs that brings us to John Mulaney
and the sack lunch bunch which debuts on
December 24th pitched as an old school
variety show and designed in the style
of Mister Rogers neighborhood the
special feature celebrity guests like
natasha Lyonne and Jake Gyllenhaal
trying to entertain children anything
with Mulaney deserves your undivided
attention so you'll definitely want to
get in on the action
on December 10th we'll be gettin
Michelle wolf jokes show a new special
from the comedian who roasted the Trump
administration at the 2018 White House
Correspondents Dinner expect her to
touch upon any number of hot-button
issues including whoa culture modern-day
feminism and much much more
if that sounds too high-minded not to
worry all three Austin Powers films will
be hitting the streaming service on
December 1st
consider it a Christmastime miracle all
right if I'm preaching to the converted
then why you being so slavish should the
three question fallen is my question
you're not even looking at me man now
you'd have been rude perhaps you'd
rather explore the grittier side of life
let it suffice to say plenty of dramatic
fare is on the way on December 6th you
can finally see whether or not marriage
story is worth all the hype directed by
Noah Baumbach the film stars Scarlett
Johansson and Adam driver as a couple
whose marriage is disintegrating
needless to say it's some heavy stuff
how are you doing on December 1st you
can get embroiled in Spike Lee's
incredible biopic Malcolm X starring
Denzel Washington or perhaps you'd
rather explore the Danish girl a moving
romantic drama starring Eddie Redmayne
that one begins streaming on December
16th then on December 29th you could
take a look at the action drama lawless
the film stars Shia LaBeouf and Tom
Hardy as two fast driving bootleggers in
prohibition-era Virginia expect lots of
shootout
let's say it's a cold night in December
and you're craving some adventure not to
worry
Netflix has got you covered on December
13th you can sink your teeth into six
underground directed by Michael Bay it
stars Ryan Reynolds as the leader of a
group of six professional criminals all
of whom have faked their own deaths
that's part of being dead is the freedom
on December 8th the spy thriller from
Paris with love will instantly add some
intrigue to your life the film stars
Jonathan Rhys Meyers in an almost
unrecognizable John Travolta as two
agents trying to thwart terrorist plots
in Paris and that's not all on December
31st you can start streaming for James
Bond movies starring Pierce Brosnan
including Die Another Day Goldeneye
Tomorrow Never Dies and the world is not
enough Netflix is banking on a lot of
monstrous fantasy fare at the end of the
year on December 5th V Wars will be
coming your way based on the popular
comic books the series stars Ian
Somerhalder as a doctor trying to save
people from a virus that turns them into
you guessed it vampires
and he's not the only square-jawed
heartthrob on the lookout for creepos
The Witcher debuts on December 20th
starring Superman's Henry Cavill as a
blond mysterious monster hunter named
Geralt of Rivia the series is an
adaptation of popular fantasy novels and
short stories by Polish author Andrzej
Sapkowski they say witches can't feel
human emotion what do you believe in
craving some science fiction you're in
luck
lost in space returns to the streamer on
December 24th and now for the festive
stuff a Christmas Prince 3 the Royal
baby is set for release on December 5th
as you may recall 2017 a Christmas
Prince involved an American journalist
named amber played by rose McIver falls
for a royal named Richard played by Ben
lamb after last year's at Christmas
Prince the Royal Wedding Queen Amber is
pregnant with the couple's first child
and she's also out to solve a mystery
that involves a missing peace treaty who
in this palace had the means the
opportunity the motive
the sacred truce is broken though
reoccur son the firstborn child
and here's another festive sequel for
you a Cinderella story Christmas wish is
the fifth installment of the film
franchise that began with 2004 a
Cinderella story that one start Hilary
Duff and Chad Michael Murray in the
latest installment an aspiring singer
named cat played by Laura Marano must
overcome her wicked step family in order
to perform at a gala meanwhile she's
falling head over heels for a certain
special someone will love prevail in the
end all these questions and more will be
answered when a Cinderella story
Christmas Wish hits Netflix on December
1st check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more loop or videos
about your favorite movies and TV shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]